Hello and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. This is the special clustered edition part
two.
We are going to be
attempting to fix some broken Kubernetes clusters. These
Kubernetes clusters are broken by friends, colleagues and
members of the community. Community. We have two
clusters today
and to help me fix them, I am
going to be joined by my friend and
colleague
Dan Fennerin. Hey Dan, how's it going?
It's going well, thank you very much. I
am
very excited and slightly nervous for today but
it should be fun.
It will definitely
be fun
whether it will be successful we'll have yet
to see.
To the people watching us and joining us
at home please remember to subscribe and click
the bell on YouTube it helps other people
find these videos and we have a discord
chat which will be visible throughout our session.
Feel free to jump in and join us
there.
Now,
why don't we just start with a quick
introduction then Dan? Why don't you tell us
a little bit about yourself and then we'll
take a look at last week's clusters.
Excellent.
Yes. So my name is Dan Finnerin.
I am part of Equinix Metal, part of
the
developer relations engineering team.
Spend a lot of my time in Kubernetes
clusters or in
the container space. I
come to Equinix Messle from Hetero VMware, and
prior to that, I was at Docker. So
I'm hoping through that I've I've accrued some
knowledge that may help me today.
I feel a little bit as though this
is punishment for being mean last week with
breaking my clusters.
But, yeah, I'm excited. Well why don't we
quickly talk about that then. So we actually
have our first comment from none other than
Waleed himself who says, hey Dan.
Hey Waleed, thank you for joining us again.
I'm gonna get you.
Well let's cover what happened week then. I've
got the
repository
up so like we want this to be
a valuable learning resource as well as entertaining
for the people that are watching and following
along. So what we're gonna try and do
week after week as we air new episodes
of clustered,
is just publish the manifests that we use
to create the clusters using cluster API on
Equinix metal but also we're going to try
and document what went wrong, what the symptoms
were and then we've also going to have
each of the breakers
just contribute and tell us what actually happened.
So
Wally joined me last week, Wally and I
were on team fixed, our clusters were broken
by Lee Briggs of Pulumi and Dan who
is with me now.
You'll see there's a readme in each of
these, we can see that cluster one from
Lee
had a small typo and the CNI slash
Cilium configuration
which broke networking on the cluster.
We discovered the symptom was that our Cilium
agents were in clash with back off, we
actually missed that, I'm not sure how I'm
gonna blame TMux, so we're not using it
today and
scrolling on TMUX is just not something I
was good at. Anyway we we managed to
fix it so that was good, it took
us twenty five minutes, it was good fun,
thank you very much Lee.
And then there's the novel that is Dan's
cluster.
So discovered symptoms, we worked out well first
and foremost SSH wasn't running on the standard
port. Mean that was just a major fuck
you right from the start Dan, come on.
I spent ten minutes trying to work out
how to go on the thing. Unfortunately you
were joining us and left us a comment
to help us out. So we did get
on the port I should have guessed but
again you get this blinker days when you've
got people watching over your We
had an unresponsive API server, it was in
crash loop back off. We discovered a few
contributing factors which we documented and then Dan
very kindly provided all of the fibr he
applied to that cluster. So lots of interesting
stuff for there to debug and fix.
I went a little bit crazy, I think.
A lot of it is kind of issues
that I tend to do when I'm kind
of quickly throwing things up though, like
building a machine
that by default has swap enabled, turn swap
off, install Kubernetes,
and then rebooting. And then the cubelet is
basically like, well, I'm not starting because swap's
enabled. Yeah. So I kind of reverted it
back to the sort of issues that I
created myself.
What I I think what I loved and
hated at the same time about everything that
you broke as well is you didn't just
do it on the control plane or do
you actually replicated it to every node in
the cluster which made fixing it all a
more painful.
Yeah. But it was good. Yeah. I
one of the issues I think I was
interesting,
I guess I hadn't really considered it, was
that once HCD got to three
three nodes as part of its configuration, breaking
that
meant that HCD would never actually reach quorum.
So fixing the first node
still left you at a point where nothing
was actually working.
Yep.
Alright. Sorry.
But but that was that was last week.
Waleed thanks for joining us today. Thanks for
joining me last week. It was a whole
lot of fun.
In fact Vale just said no, don't worry
Dan. It was fun. Which just means leads
at me. I'm curious to see what will
lead. Will lead is one of our breakers
today. So a couple more highs. Hi
Benziden. Nice to see you.
Hey Mark, how's it going? Good to see
you. Of course we've got Nuno thanks for
joining us.
Yeah awesome, oh sorry Frank I missed you,
there we go. There's all the hellos done.
Feel free to jump into discord or use
YouTube comments as we go, we will definitely
appreciate the help. This is
a little difficult at times.
Alright, so we're not using TMux today.
I have been slightly more prepared and I
want us to be able to still have
that TMux flexibility or teammate function functionality where
we can actually share a terminal type together,
but with actual decent scrolling. So today we're
using teleport,
which means we have an SSH connection open
on our first node with RAM PS to
make sure it works. Dan has the same
on his side. Dan type hello.
You've
lost the window. Should have warned you. There
we go. So we're gonna try
and take it a little bit slower
and
methodological,
I'm
Scottish I think a Methodically.
Methodically.
Thank you. Try
and fix this together, taken, try to follow
each other's hypothesis and really explain what we're
thinking as we go. So
I guess
really what we wanna do first and I'm
gonna jump to my local terminal first just
because I do have a cube config there
and I'm gonna run just to get nodes.
I guess, I mean that's the best way
to get started, isn't it?
We're on cluster
three, this was broken by one of our
colleagues Jason
Does that strike fear into you a little
bit? It does. I I I'm I'm intrigued.
I know he is
well into the internals of Kubernetes
So I
I don't know what he may have may
have may have done, but I guess it's
time to try and find out. As you
mentioned,
I guess, this methodically, so we'll kind of
test from outside in
by
poking it from the outside,
seeing what works, what doesn't works and then
starting to go layer by layer until we
hopefully
find out what he's done.
Nice. Alright. Let's just tackle a few more
and we'll get started. Well he'd asked if
we have it CD backups. That's
terrifying.
Alex is joining us, Anise you're definitely not
too late for hello's, thanks for joining us
and Sandy Blaber, hey,
alright let's fix some stuff. So
one thing I got stuck on last week
as I didn't realize that get component statuses
was actually deprecated so this is well I'm
on the wrong cube con pic,
gave myself a heart attack already. Well,
it's not responding anyway. Just
a little bit slower. I can't remember where
I stuck this cluster actually. I think
maybe in Chicago,
so there might be a little bit of
latency but teleport will fix that. Anyway, component
status is supposed to red heading last week.
This has been deprecated for a few releases
I've now found out, so we can ignore
those errors and I'm really happy that we
even got a response anyway, we can even
run a get nodes.
That's a healthy This
is worrying though, this is where you immediately
start tripping yourself up and thinking we're on
an easy street.
Yeah, yeah, definitely got that.
So,
so that we can type together, I guess
the best thing for us to do is
just export a cube config here
use the admin token.
Mhmm. Make sure we can still get notes.
Okay. Okay. So I'm gonna let you
I'll let you take for a little bit.
Why don't you do a little bit of
explanation and see if we can find out
for So
these have something running on them, don't they?
There is a WordPress workload that runs on
all clusters clusters, which we should be able
to, I mean I can port forward to
it locally and browse to it if you
want or you can have curl whatever you
feel like, but you should be able to
have that IP on port 80 or I
guess you can use the node port there.
If you wanna do local host and 30314
or do that.
Oh, I forgot I configured
load balancing.
Yeah.
So
So that's Our workload works.
Okay. Well, I put forward to it just
for the and see if we can browse
to actually in a real visual browser.
I want I'm just gonna have a quick
look at some other
well, let's have a look at actually what's
running on there first, I think, and then
we'll
if that's okay. Yeah. Of course. Go for
it.
Before we before we start looking into applications,
let's
let's actually see what's what's kinda running on
here. I have often wondered if a customer's
only automatically fix itself in some way, but
I hope that never happens.
So we have a Cilium namespace with all
of the the
various components that are required for Cilium.
We have default namespace where we have our
application running.
And then in cube system,
API server, various proxies,
core DNS,
the packet or Equinix metal cloud controller manager.
And
looking here for things that have rebooted a
number of times or have been restarted.
There are a few things, but normally, we
would see things restart,
namely during the convergence of all these components
actually coming up
and
all of the ceph
components for our persistent storage. Storage.
So, I mean, from the outside,
everything is kind of looking okay.
Did he forget to break our cluster? I'm
sure not. I I did see him
saying that everything should be should be working
okay.
Everything should be I'm sorry. I saw a
message from him saying that he had finished
breaking everything last night. So
I guess the kind of thing is that
we're gonna have to determine what's broken here.
So how how do you want me to
go about that?
I mean, do you do you want to
deploy a new workload on there and see
what happens? Or
Yeah. Why don't we
try and modify the WordPress?
Let's try and pretend we're doing an upgrade
of our WordPress component. We'll change the tag
on that WordPress image
and we'll see if anything breaks through there.
So
is this a deployment or is it just
a single? It's a deployment code word pressure.
Might come out outside. Oh, there we go.
I'm not so bad. It's just
the elicit now before we Yeah. Before
we forget.
And so let's just change that tag, right?
Like just take the Apache off and do
a 4.8.
We'll just force that to pull a new
image and see what happens.
Yes,
one second. Yeah, do it though. I'll do
that repeatedly as well.
So that could be pulling an image,
we could describe it and see the event
log just to confirm or we can just
be patient which is definitely not one of
my strong suits.
No patience has already expired. I see what's
going on.
I
forgot to play.
I apologize.
What? It's running.
This is confusing.
Okay. I wonder what he's done.
I wonder what's actually broken here then.
So let's confirm our WordPress is working. I
am gonna do the port forward now and
browse to it. Make sure it's hitting my
scale. It's getting post. It's happy.
I'll let
you drive them. Yeah. I'll just do that
from,
I guess I could do the put forward
from
Sorry. You know, I'll do it for my
machine now.
Okay. Get pods
for
forward.
Eighty, eighty, 80. And then I'll jump over
to my browser.
Well, I haven't installed WordPress yet, but it
is working.
I'm sure I did that. There's no three.
Well,
sure.
And if I remove this,
it's speaking to the database.
There's nothing
obvious.
Yes. I shouldn't type here.
I wonder what we're missing here then.
I mean, we have a working API server,
our workload is intact, we have no,
there's no pods aren't happy.
Yeah. That's I'm gonna I will try and
deploy. I'm gonna quickly deploy NGINX and expose
it. Yeah. Go for it. See see what
happens.
So
this is from
the case examples.
So we have NGINX deployed,
and I am now gonna expose this. You
know what?
I think we are in the wrong cluster.
I bet you Jason's
clustered four and I'm just making an absolute
arse of this.
Well, I'd like to imagine we've done a
very good job of debugging our working person
profile.
Although
this hasn't exposed us. Oh, there we go.
That might take a little while anyway as
it gets to my p address. Okay.
I don't know if you want to check
whether O4O4 is the one that we should
film them.
Yep. What I'm gonna do is we are
gonna have to jump to teammate for this
one then. So I'll send you the link.
I just moved to off screen.
We're gonna have to do this one the
hard way but that's alright.
Well, least we're warmed up now. Well, yeah.
We've shown everyone how to check a working
cluster.
Jason's probably going, I had no idea what
they're doing. I shouldn't bark.
So
we'll use teleport for the WALI cluster.
So let me export
the cube config.
You've got the command. Let me know when
you're in. We can test it. We type
it. Let's run get pods.
Are we looking with something that's a bit
more broken?
We see a broken thing.
One second.
Okay, I'm in.
Alright, we've got a control player node which
is very much unhappy.
A worker node which is very much unhappy.
Our pods at least look okay and the
workload namespace.
I'll show the SSH command anyway. Oops.
I trust y'all. That's a stupid idea but
and now I need to remember how to
do
scrolling and t max.
There we go.
Alright, so I think
we just need to get some control plane
notes online.
So how do you wanna start debugging this
then? Here's
our first symptom, two notes offline and do
you wanna SSH onto one of them? Do
you wanna do some cube commands? What do
wanna do first?
I mean, we could do a describe nodes
or see if there's any events
on the node that is not that is
not ready.
I think we probably can hop straight onto
the SSH onto that node and see its
current state.
Alright. Let's take a look at JSC.
Alright. I'll let you drive from now on
since you've got you've got a plan.
Alright.
Okay.
So what's normally What would be the first
thing you'd wanna look at when you see
that a node is offline or not ready?
What so, I mean, normally, a node that
is no longer
marked as ready has either been powered off,
rebooted, or the cubelet has basically stopped responding.
So my first step really would be to
check that the cubelet is actually up and
running,
which it is.
Oh, pot thickens. Okay. That's fine.
But why is it not ready?
I guess we maybe wanna take a look
at the kiblet logs.
Yes.
So
Connection refused. I see a few of those
scrolling past. Yeah.
Okay. So we basically set that to follow
so we can start to see everything that's
going on.
There are a lot of errors here. Well,
the cubelet is
trying to so what's the IP address of
this box?
So it's trying to loop back to itself
to speak to the local API server component.
So
the kubelet
the kubelet's main role is
to start a bunch of static pods from
static manifests
of which the API server is one of
them
and also to be given instruction by those
API servers in order to
to start things.
So
let's see
what is actually up and running
from
a cube perspective, I suppose.
So we have the scheduler.
We have the controller.
We have the cubelet. We have cube proxy.
The API server isn't starting, though. We could
see that in the cubelet logs.
And I I guess the other component that
we need to check
is etcd,
which
also
doesn't appear to be running.
Now if etcd is not running,
it looks to me like it's probably
issue.
We kinda saw this before
in that
etcd
needs to bind to all of the other
nodes in order for it to come up
successfully,
and the API server
needs to be able to speak to the
XCD server in order for that to work
as well.
Yep.
So
So just my point of view, right, is
like Yeah. We can see the Qplet running.
We can see the connection refused.
I think if we can get past that
first to try and identify the networking issue
there, do you think that's likely to maybe
assuming
there's some sort of root misconfiguration or IP
table blocking it, we can maybe that would
bring the other components online or
is that not a fair assessment?
Yeah. That's that's fair to me. I I
think the problem here is that XCD
can't speak to the other XCD
the other XCD members. But that wouldn't cause
a connection refused on the Qiplet, would it?
It will so the connection you're seeing there
is it trying to speak to the API
server.
The API server can't speak to the NCD
services cascading failures.
Let's
I guess, should we get some ETCD logs?
Yes. So
so there's ETCD.
Oh, these are siblings, aren't they?
Uh-oh.
And if I'm reading that correctly, has he
explicitly downgraded one of the members of the
cluster?
I think what I'm seeing here is
he's actually
possibly removed
from this
member.
It doesn't appear to have any idea of
other members to join.
But why Sorry.
On your go.
There's also the new raft
line, which is the second error mess second
log
second to last log
entry.
Okay. So is that line that says cluster
cannot be downgraded current version is lower than
the term clustered version, a red herring?
I think so because it's not joining.
It doesn't appear to be
attempting to join
any other
there's there's no mention of it trying to
join the rest of cluster.
Well, there's a restarting member in cluster with
two unique IDs.
Okay. So
can we take a look at the entity
configuration and see if it is configured to
speak to the other two control play notes?
Yes. I mean, we can
I'm already concerned. I'm going I've I've talked
to myself into a corner here about something
that's possibly wrong. But Well, I don't see
any conflict there. So why don't we take
a look at the system d unit file
for it to do? They Or the manifest?
Yes.
Yeah. I keep forgetting the static manifest for
XCD.
So red herring here, the date has changed
on the XCD manifest compared to all the
others. These are all created at the same
time.
Yeah.
So what what have you done?
Alright. I'm gonna need you to explain every
argument past the STD here.
Everybody
hold on to your app.
So effectively, this config is generated
by
kubeadm
and
it will create these manifests
and and give it all the information it
needs in order for this to come up.
Given that we appear to be having some
sort of networking
or some sort of binding issue of things
coming up. I presume that something in here
is not the way it's meant to be.
So
what have you done?
People are enjoying watching us suffer here. I've
gotta tell you that. I I think what
we could do is possibly look at one
of the other
one of the other manifests or one of
the other control
plane nodes and see what that looks like
and compare the two. Yeah. Do a state
by state comparison. Definitely. Yep.
Alright.
Tell you what, why don't we
Wrong button.
Aljet is on to the other node.
I'll just grab the oh, that closed that.
Okay.
Four.
Okay. Four. Get nodes white. I'll just grab
them all. But no. We just want control
plane.
And we'll just grab one of those working
ones.
So
How how are doing for time?
Plenty. Yeah. Okay. That's fine then.
No no rush.
Talk amongst yourselves. Alright. Well, mean, if I
knew how to do a vertical split that,
you know,
may have a horizontal split that might have
helped do a side by side comparison but
if you could want to just scroll the
top one and we'll try and do it
roughly at the same time like synchronize shelling.
Oh
no we can't do that because it's not
two cursors, one. Alright
okay.
So
let's see what do we got.
Well the advertised client URL should be different
right? That's each each
unique node just doing this thing. Server search
okay, it's off true.
Direct The list of members
looks
one second. The initial advertised peer URLs,
would that be
the it's on URL as well? I guess
so. Yes. That's I believe that's when it
first starts up the first time.
The initial cluster,
the reason why those those are different, I
believe, is due to what nodes it is
aware of when you actually do the Kube
ADM join.
Okay.
So
the node on the bottom half will have
only been aware of itself and whatever was
itself when it was being added.
The one at the top will have been
the last node to join, so it will
have been aware of the the first two
and it being the third. That's why there's
three there on the
initial cluster flag.
Keep going down.
All ports are correct.
I will loop back
a little bit further, please.
Okay. Three dot three snapshot count, and the
image is different.
Yep.
I told you it was the image.
I'm I'm just gonna sit here quietly I
think.
Okay. Let's
let's at least lay them up. Right? So
I what I saw in the log with
that downgraded version thing made me think that
because
there's obviously some sort of data format change
on the disk, couldn't load the data as
it couldn't join the cluster, it's kinda where
let's let's try it. Right? Reload,
in fact it's not reload. You shouldn't need
to do anything.
Oh, yeah. The pods have just come up.
Right? Yeah. The cubelet will check the shards
or the m d fives or whatever and
realize that the static pod manifest has changed
at which point it will restart it.
Okay.
Let's make our lives a little bit simpler
here. So get pods
cube system,
grab that CD.
Oh, well, I'm on the node that's not
gonna work in that CD so that was
smart.
Maybe on its way back up again at
this point.
Yeah. Looks like it. Let's
check the logs and find out if there's
anything else wrong with that CD, I suppose.
Alright. Those were in Barlab containers. Right?
Barlab containers? Oh, that's
Yeah. You're right.
And then we catered the FCD file.
So it's established,
blah blah blah, with all of its peers.
I see a lot of infos.
I
It looks happier. Yeah. It does look a
little bit happier. Yep.
Health is okay from the endpoint.
It looks like our API server still hasn't
come up though.
Cube API.
I'll make sure I've got messed up that.
Yeah. Okay. So now we need to work
out the API server problem.
So in here, it should be the the
API server logs.
Yep.
That is
failing to connect to local hosts
and when did that fail last? Yeah.
That was four minutes ago.
It's four four minutes ago.
So that's 12:29. We're 12:33 at the moment.
Okay.
Why is that restarted?
Okay. Let's see if we can do a
countless containers.
Well, that didn't work last week either. Maybe
that's just that command. I think that's yeah.
So why is the API server not restarted?
Let's make sure it's in the manifests.
Yep.
There it is. And in theory, that doesn't
really look like it's been modified.
I mean, he could have been really sneaky
and changed the date on that, but you're
right. Probably unlikely.
Well, yeah. I mean, it could have been
very sneaky. That would be very good. That
would be very sneaky to do that. Now
we're giving people hints for future episodes. But
Yes.
So if I drive for a few minutes
Please please do. Yeah. Go for it. Around.
I mean, I don't feel like there's gonna
be any major issues with this,
But let's check that that CD is actually
listening to where we expect it to be
listening.
Well, it's listening on 2379,
and something is looping back to it as
well.
Now the API server has come up
What we've been
Well, so we hold on. Maybe we were
just a bit quick then. Like, how long
would it take for a member in the
NCD cluster to really join the quorum and
get healthy again? Were we just impatient?
Etcd can take a little while
but there's also
cubelet which
may I I don't know off the top
of my head but maybe that has some
level of crash back
before it actually comes up.
I think we've there's no doubt it's ready.
I ran get nodes.
Looks like we just wanna jump on to
worker or
TW seven.
Okay. Let's see if we can get this
one healthy then. So
yeah. We confident this machine's okay? Yeah.
Well, the FCD has rejoined the quorum.
The API server is looping back to the
FCD instance
and reporting itself as ready.
Alright. So from my perspective, this node looks
okay.
We've yet to try and run workload on
it. So I mean, we could be we
could be back here
for long king through logs at any moment.
We'll see in a minute. Let's get
this one.
Okay. So this node is unready. Now, I
guess very much like the first node, what
we wanna do is we wanna check that
the core components are running. So we're gonna
look for the API server.
No. We're look for to be No. No.
It's not API server. No. We have a
kubelet. Alright. Okay. So
oh, no. We don't have a kubelet.
We have a CSI node driver registrar.
Okay. So this one has nothing.
So
kubelet normally runs as a system d unit
or a system d
instance.
So
first thing really would be to check whether
that actually exists.
Okay.
Oh.
It's it's a worker. There'll be no admin.com
from here.
Of course, silly me.
Alright. So you wanted to check if there
was a system d kubelet.
So there we go.
We have some errors.
Let's
So there's something very wrong with the config
for this cubelet by the looks of things.
There's about a terabyte of logs fly past.
It looks like something has broken the flags
on this so that it is
it's basically instead of it working, it's error
printing out all of the flags as in
you've missed done one of the flags here,
all of the flags work out what you've
done wrong.
So I think
we could do to be able to scroll
around in these logs to work out where
Why don't we just try stopping the service
and running the complete command
manually
try and
Well, so at the top of all of
this output should be the line that it's
finding wrong as in we passed the wrong
flag.
Okay. Let's take a look.
Yeah. You're gonna need that no
page or Here we go.
Unknown flag bootstrap config.
So this is the issue. Oh, this appears
to be the issue.
We are passing a flag that it doesn't
understand.
Right. Well, I guess we should go take
a look at that unit fail.
So this is either going to be in
the kubelet config.
You can pass additional flags in some of
the files that the kubelet config imports,
or it will be in the the system
d unit files as you mentioned.
So we will start with
it's in system.
It is. So
this is the config that system d uses
to start it with to begin with. Hold
on a minute. I I I'm not I
can't let that slide by. More? Who uses
more?
I do because I want I want more.
And
yeah. No. I should use less. But
Sorry. I didn't mean to ruin your train
of thought there. No. That's that's fine.
So
we can see here there is the dash
dash bootstrap dash cube config.
The line on the top oops.
My crazy mouse just gone a bit crazy
there.
It appears to be this line that's causing
it problem.
The cube, like, cube config RX?
Yes. Where we are passing that dash dash
bootstrap dash cube config.
Now
I don't even think there's anything in the
bootstrap kubelet conf anyway.
There normally isn't.
Am I gonna now have to live with
the fact that I use more?
I been mocks for it.
I haven't used more since, you know, 02/2003.
So
I mean, I'm all for just basically removing
the dash dash bootstrap dash q config because
there's nothing even in that file to read.
However
Let's try it. We I mean, we do
have a q config parameter after it. So
the bootstrap config, I'm not really sure.
You know?
Yeah. I I I think you're right. Let's
let's remove that and then see where we
are after that.
I mean, again, I we could, you know,
kinda go away and look at what
is on the other nodes.
Just whilst we're in here as well.
Okay.
I mean, the bootstrap command was the one
that I had issue with.
And we can
oops.
I mean if that worked, system d would
have attempted to restart it by now.
Okay.
Do we need to do anything for system
d to pick those up or should it
just? No. We didn't modify the unit files
so we don't need to do a reload.
Okay. We can just
It would appear still a little unhappy.
Yep. We're not getting a kubelet. Let's jump
back into the
pager.
Invalid argument.
My
my tmux foo is particularly poor. So
it seems
I don't see an error.
Pairs that describe resources as for non Kubernetes
components.
That's that's just output from
minus
h.
It don't appear to be getting much. It
might have been silly.
We need
to get to the top of because it
the problem is when kubelet fails with a
wrong argument, it prints out like a mega
random
additional flags that it could be.
See, thought that yellow line meant that's the
the most recent restart and I thought that
would just show me what I wanted.
There we go. Okay. So now
that shift key took away. I was a
little worried there. There we go.
Oh, it skips out the bits we need
to see if that's helpful.
Yeah. We we we
I'm gonna stop it. Right? So
I mean I hate fighting with journal d
so what I'm gonna suggest is we do
this, we cat that, we do a
kubelet,
kube config
equals
etcetera.
Kubernetes,
kubelet dot conf,
config equals bar.
I can work with.
I see. Okay.
So
it couldn't parse that triplet
config. Let me
I don't know what happened there either.
And it cannot connect to the Docker daemon,
which we aren't running Docker, so that makes
sense.
Yeah. That's where the error is. So if
we look to the left,
we can see there's a w one I
info e for error
is basically the reason why it's not not
running.
I wonder whether someone has changed this conflict
to use docker instead of container d.
Alright. I guess we should take a look
at that then.
So
is that in the
this file
here, kubelet comp?
No. That's the that's the for the cert.
So it's the config here? Config that yaml.
Yeah.
Normally in here you would find the what
was it in here?
I'm assuming the lack of CRI configuration
maybe defaults to Docker on this version of
Kubernetes.
So maybe we need to actually provide the
configuration for that.
Should we pull up another working work worker
node?
Yeah. Start with the quickest and easiest way.
I don't think there's gonna be much in
here that's actually node specific.
Alright.
Grab one of these.
One four five.
Put one to the broken one, David. And
we just really wanna compare this to Yep.
This config.
I'll just commit config gamble.
Yeah. Don't know what happened there.
So
I
don't see anything
that says container d on it
socket or Yeah. I'm not seeing any socket
anywhere.
Maybe not this fail. In fact, we can
use that we trick that you've now taught
everybody who's like, has this fail even changed?
No.
Alright. So
let's
so the cube that can be modified with
additional configuration
by passing parameters to the unit failed. Did
we maybe miss something in there?
Yeah. I think we'll open up the unit
file one more time and see what else
it imports for config paths.
Where was that for
system d?
Alright.
Not that one, so it's this one.
There we go. So
it could be the QBDM flags
or the default file.
That's all we've got. Yep.
Okay.
Farnib.
He's
definitely making his run around. Is that right?
Is that right? Remote and is that socket
path correct?
Well, the easiest way is to quickly compare
it on the other node.
So if we pop through the pane and
look at the same one.
They are the same.
So
One other thing then to check is to
whether he's actually changed the path of container
d as well.
So whilst that's open, if we should do
an l s on the path to
slash run slash container d slash container d
dot sock.
No. It's run. It's run container d. Container
d
container d. Container dot sock. Okay. That's it.
So there was that one other fail, wasn't
there,
that could provide overwrites?
Slash etsy default.
Doesn't exist. Okay.
That's interesting then.
Yes.
So as far as we are concerned,
our kubelet is configured to correctly speak to
container d but for some weird reason as
trying to speak to Docker.
I'm gonna close this other one for now.
Does the kubelet fall back to alternative run
times if the configured run time fails? Like
in my head I'm thinking, is it are
we messing somewhere the config has been overwritten
to tell to use Docker or is it
doing that as a fallback because it can't
speak to container d? Do we know? I'm
not sure. I'm okay driving for a second.
Should not have a quick one more look
at the cubelet logs. Please do. I'm ready
to leave.
Everyone, I'm using less.
So
Okay. So bootstrap config, we know that doesn't
work.
Let's set the timer. What's the
How do I get to the end here
so I can go up?
We've had a few comments. Next suggests our
kubelet version may have changed.
Alex is saying could it be permissions on
the socket?
Both things we should probably confirm. Yeah, definitely.
One sec. Let me
try to get to a recent log. There's
so many logs in here. It's really hard
to find them.
Yeah. Why don't just run it manually the
way we did earlier? Just control r dot
kubect command and then just get the output
from that. That'll be a bit easier.
One second.
So
I was looking for about the bootstrap. When
did we change that? That was quite a
while ago, isn't it? Well, yeah. The failed
that exist so we removed the flag.
So let's go to five minutes ago.
That isn't.
So you could point from what we're just
saying couldn't we just rejoin the node. We
could just use QD, QDM to rejoin, but,
you know, would be nice We could. Because
it would be nice to dig in and
fix it.
So still complaining. Let's move to what's the
time now? 12:51.
So what are you looking for?
I am just flipping forward through the logs
to a more recent
oh, so this has not been restarted since
12:44.
So
Oh, I stopped the kubelet. Stop.
To run it manually.
Sorry. Cool.
No. That's fine.
No. It wants a reload. How do we
need to with the new config?
Demon. Oh, there we go. Silly me.
And start.
Yeah. I wonder if we fixed it and
then just forgot to start it there. I
forgot
to start it as I look shifty.
No. We still have no so
we can
grab the logs one more time.
There is a last flag isn't there? I
keep forgetting.
Scroll.
Let's see if we can find the start
this time.
This is 2AM. This is these these aren't
the right logs.
I think it's last.
Shift g, let it jump down.
There we go.
Okay. What are we completing that? Config has
been deprecated.
Unknown cloud provider.
Let's put on our no page.
If anyone in the chat knows how to
just get the last 50 lanes.
I
have a bit of a brain blank at
the moment and I just can't
remember.
Oh, dear.
I'm
gonna Google it.
Journal
CTL
last
yeah. There we go. Last 100 lines I'll
do.
Dash n, okay. Not
super responsive to my control c, but hopefully
that's just a standard out flush.
Alright. Okay.
Dash n 100 please. There we go.
Use pod manifest happens that I know the
provider external worries me more than the config
being deprecated.
Let's
check the
version.
Oh, for one
four seven.
This is a 1.2
Yes. Zero cluster.
I mean, in the real world, I'm not
entirely sure how many people would find a
version of Cubelet that's, like, three years old.
You happy with that? I'm very happy with
We actually had a one nineteen four available.
Maybe just over overkill the binary.
I'll
put it back to the version that thinks
installed.
So I think he's been out of his
way to find a really old kubelet binary
and just dropped in the machine.
Yeah. Mean, so the the error that you
were getting there is I guess cloud providers
weren't even a thing back then.
But, yeah, effectively,
that was mean. I like that.
I mean, congratulations.
That that was that was mean.
That's just my alias
that I got wrong.
I don't actually know. I don't work on
how to You won't be able to there's
no admin.com for anything. I need to go
to one of the other ones.
Alrighty.
So we pop back to the control plane
or your your local terminal.
Ta da.
Okay. That was a good one. I like
that. That was good.
Well done.
That was that was interesting. I mean, yeah,
I it does it can happen.
It's just I I I after watching last
week, was I was in my head, I
was like, don't get dragged into looking in
the wrong place. Don't get dragged down the
rabbit holes.
And that's exactly what's occurring right here.
So actually, missed Nick's comment, but he called
it earlier. I reckon it's an old Kooplit
binary.
Well done mate.
Alright. Well I mean maybe I should just
sit and read the YouTube comments and do
this much quicker.
Yeah.
I I you
know, never thought to check the version. You
obviously never thought to check the version. I
just that was a
I suppose why why would I though? You
know, cluster APIs install all this. It's all
installed the same version. Why?
Okay.
Nice work, Jason. Let's jump over to Wally's
cluster.
Was that Jason's cluster, was it? Yes.
Okay.
We got there.
We did. Doesn't
matter.
I feel like, yeah, maybe I should have
checked the version correctly but I think we
were we were
we did go slow and we we talked
and we we thought about it. I just
I guess it just never occurred to us
and
there was the STD issue as well which
we fixed. Couple of really smart
issues there. Alright, well at least cluster, let's
try to teleport this time so we don't
have to t mux and I don't have
to remember all those weird emaxi style shortcuts.
Okay.
Well let's just jump on to our control
plane note
and you should be able to join the
session. I will zoom in on the
terminal.
Yeah, I think that looks alright.
Now Waleed tell me upfront there's potentially a
readme available.
He doesn't tell me where.
I know you're in the chat Waleed if
you wanna save me a few clicks feel
free to tell us where the read me
is.
What I'll do first is my
of the alias.
Have you joined the session yet? Okay.
I am I just need to get my
my authenticator access up and running. I'm now
in the
well then, what have we got?
Oh, I got a broken cluster.
Alright. Like, he says it's not on this
control plane notes. I'm gonna pop open.
There we go. We do have a read
me.
Hi, David. Thank you for giving me and
the auditor a chance to check cluster 005.
So other say things are not always as
they seem,
the first appearances deceive many.
Also a user passed by and reported pods
cannot access the API server, she was testing
with from inside a pod to verify with
this command. Best of luck, I
love that you set a scene, thanks.
Like that, set the mood.
Yeah,
let's get our alias on this machine as
well
And we did, I think the
get nodes failed on that other machine didn't
it? So probably gonna fail from here too.
So I guess it's the same,
I mean our starting steps are just gonna
be the same, right? We wanna check for
the core components running on this machine
see if we can identify some really obvious
things upfront. So
kiblet.
You didn't grab.
We do have a kiblet.
We do have an API server
and I thought we really need to get
started. We have an entity so
things look alright up front.
But
so the error that we had was that
we well, we didn't get an error, but
we kubectl
should speak to
you used the admin.com from this one, didn't
you?
I did.
And that will have its local address and
port in there,
right at the top.
Oh yeah.
So
that's over our I mean, could change that
to 127001.
Would that work?
Yeah. That would be fine.
And I believe it should be signed for
local host. If not, then you'll get a
TLS error.
But, I mean, we can just
look at net stats to see if it's
actually up and running on that port.
Alright. So first of all, I'm gonna
so that IP address should be the IP
address of this machine. Right?
It should. Yeah.
So we've got two IP no. One IPV
four 80 seven 30 eight.
Yep.
LN.
What would you use here?
A n
and grep for six four four three.
Yeah. It's there.
We have an established connection to that, so
I'm gonna assume it's alright.
The get nodes didn't work.
Is that alright?
Maybe I'll let it actually time out. Give
me an error this time.
Timed out. SCD timed out, not the API
server. Oh, okay.
That's strange.
I hate SCD problems.
Is the STD running on this this node
Well,
I mean it looks like it of course.
It certainly does.
So is there
is there a way for us to check
the health? I mean, if entity is running
to me, that normally means that it's healthy
because it wouldn't be able to join the
cluster otherwise.
Yeah. I mean, the first thing probably would
be check the FCD logs, find out what
it's saying and how healthy it thinks it
is.
K.
In fact, we can just go to top
Follow-up containment.
Oh,
no.
It's your bad data in our etcd.
Failed to apply.
There is a c t m space.
So it looks like a a value to
be oh, no desk?
No desk space.
I'm sorry. I managed to log on if
that was the case. No. This looks alright.
And although it's running on a container, let's
take a look at our manifest for this
and see if there's any weird configuration.
Oh, it's running read only or something like
that.
Possibly before we start.
We do have a volume but I don't
believe those are no. That is the data
directory. Varlib etcd.
And that volume is
a host path
here.
No, that's not the same one, is it?
No. Etcd data. Where's Etcd data?
Oh yeah.
Varlib Etcd.
Not a special mode path or anything, is
it?
No.
Yeah.
So it's not the horse which leads me
to must be something to do with the
I don't know.
I'm
not an Nets CD expert if I can
kind of
I
wanna go back to
to this.
Let me go through a little bit slower.
So I'm not worried about the commands. I
don't think there's anything there. You can't tell
STD not to rate to this location. We've
got varlib etcd as the data there. So
let's confirm that's where we meant it. Yeah.
So varlib
that
looks
alright.
I'm not fussed about the probes resource. There's
no constraints or limits.
I mean, there's
there's nothing there
that makes me think that can't run.
And that CD is running, but it's failing.
Yes.
And does that CD have a fixed size
database? Is there too much in it? Or
I wouldn't
where's my CD does have a yeah. Does
have a command line thing, isn't it? It
does, but I can never remember how to
do it and I always fall back on
one of these
things so
Well there'll be a lesson to you Google
is the answer. Always.
Alright. We don't actually have the etcd command
line tools.
And if I could remember how to do
a NS enter into that
mount fail system, I would.
In fact, we could just do that. Right?
It's pet
three nine eight zero seven nine.
LSNS.
NS enter.
Let's see if I can remember the syntax
on this.
N s. We want the mount namespace.
Don't know how you do that? Oh no.
There's a number and the namespace mount and
then
I'll
remember. I'll get there. Yeah. NS enter
four zero two. This is the last time
I'm trying. I know there's a way to
do this.
Screw you NS enter.
NS enter m.
If I much need to install it, see
download it from
I know it should it should. 398079.
I'm gonna try one more thing. Okay.
Or pet ah, okay.
Maybe I just need that.
No, right, pain, forget it.
I'm gonna Google that for the next pain
because that's twice I felt that Anna Center
would have been really useful.
We just need that CD client, don't we?
Well, that keeps failing.
We may just have to grab the x
c d binary then from
Okay.
Tripped up by the silly things.
I'm gonna grab the lot by those things.
AMD sixty four.
Curl l.
Extract.
That's more than I want to. Oh my
goodness.
NCT.
There we go. Okay. So
NCT,
CTL.
Oh, what? Did you grab Mac OS one?
Why am I my host?
Oh, you're in the prop file system trying
to download it there.
I'm shooting myself in foot far too much
here anyway.
SCD
CTL.
Alright. Where's
that cheat sheet?
I've exported all those things which should get
us started.
Let's test this command works.
Alright. We have the ability to query etcd.
Wow. That's wonderful.
Yeah. I think it's just binary keys inside
of that to be fair.
Looking at
the
effects of the logs for not the logs,
the Kubernetes documentation for NCD,
there are a number of things that we
can actually kind of start to look at
to determine
kind of the current state of it.
Things like the snapshot
size and things like that.
I need this pointer to just tell link
in the docs, s c d op gate
maintenance.
I'm assuming that's gonna have some commands on
it.
Space quota. Yeah. That sounds
so table endpoint status, I guess.
Do you wanna tape if you know what
you're doing?
I do. I do not know what I'm
doing, but oh, I'm gonna kick out again.
One second.
I'm just gonna type health and see if
anything does anything. No.
I should know more etcd stuff.
Well, mean if you're lucky, you never really
have to touch etcd.
Which node are you on? M5.
M 5 R Zed G. Yep.
Okay.
I'm not sure what's happened.
Yeah
my screen seems to have since
you joined it just went up at ski
west but I'll just keep scrolling down manually.
It says it's healthy.
Yeah.
Should we run that compaction?
I just wanna get the
one second.
There was a size command which should.
Yeah. I saw the size command for setting
it. I never saw a way to query
it.
Let's see.
Quarter back end size.
Woah. Do we need to
because scrolling's a bit weird sometimes.
Yeah. I've had a bit of issues there
with it.
Watch version blah blah blah. Snapshot status.
Yeah. If we do that,
write out table endpoint status. Did you run
that? There's
also an entity control alarm list which I
think will list out some problems.
No space. So
I think we're getting close to working out
where we're looking here. Okay. There was also
the
fact let me just drop this command and
then see if it works.
It seems to list something.
There we go. So we've got an endpoint
state is there looking at the table and
we can see
the size, the DB size is 18 meg.
So I guess we're gonna have to increase
that or do a compaction to free up
some space.
Yes.
So compact will compact the event history as
we can see here.
I'm guessing our our events we have that
many events that there's no space left. So
Well, we just set well, we just make
it really big.
Yeah. That's entirely too really.
Alright. Well, I've got that command from the
maintenance gauge. Let's set this to we don't
want 16 meg. I'm gonna go for
a gig.
Oh no, you start at CD with a
quarter back inside. Okay. So we're gonna have
to modify
the static manifest to change the quota back
end sites.
Do we have one?
No. Okay. So
one zero two four.
You happy?
Yeah.
No. I'm not sure if it's static manifest,
but that automatically restart. Do we need to
Yes. It will do.
Any change to static manifest will be detected
by Qubelet.
It keeps track of all those files.
So it should restart at CD.
Alright. Well,
Jason has now joined us. Hey, man. We
spent a solid hour on your cluster. Thanks
for that.
Alright.
Let's
see.
So we should be able to do that
right endpoint status again.
Etcd's been up.
It's not been restarting the system. That's just
a cube API server, isn't it? So
I've now broken it.
Tail
etcd.
Alright. We need more.
I've made it worse.
Invalid value, flag if I missed that. Okay.
It doesn't like the
the math where the you've added in.
Alright. I guess I can just type a
big number.
Yeah. Of course, that shell expansion is not
gonna work in a static manifest.
There we go. So
we had a rake. I loved it control
r just worked in that and that's a
browser window. That was awesome.
And I changed the retriever.
Where did I
It's in your home directory, isn't it? Yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah. There we go. Okay. So right at
table.
It's
still 80 meg.
What's
what does the compact actually do then? Will
that not help us yet?
So there seems to be a defrag and
a compact.
Will we try both?
I don't really know what defrag does but
I remember what it used to do in
my old hard drives back in the day.
Yeah.
Compact?
Well, it needs one argument. I should look
at the docs but.
The revision number, I think, for compact.
Do I pick a random number?
It's version three, isn't it?
That's CD. I'm look I'm looking at the
XCD logs there.
If it's just the three at once? No.
I think it's getting the revision from that
write out table.
Oh, that's the wrong terminal. Need to stop
doing that.
Write out. Is there a revision here?
Is it grabbing it from that version?
313.
Alright. I'll just try three then.
That would be a nope.
Out of range, required revision has been compacted.
What?
Yeah. There is some sort of revision and
there are write out JSON. So sorry. I
keep on doing the wrong thing.
That write out command, I guess the dash
o JSON is gonna give us
more.
I'll write out equals JSON.
This is why you should read the documentation
instead of.
To have j q
I don't see the oh, there's the revision
there. Oh, there. 730154.
3 0 1 5
4.
Compacted. Okay.
Let's go back to the table output and
see if it's still got an alarm and
it does. Although the db size is now
only five meg.
So
I have no idea what we're doing.
Yeah. I I how's it still complaining now
that we've reduced the
it appears to be no longer the leader
either.
Should we go to the leader, I guess?
Like
I don't know whether we need to replicate
this across all of the members.
Let's try it. We already have another machine
here. We'll copy the etcd cheat sheet.
Where's my cheat sheet? To set up etcd.
And I don't have the binary again.
Hello.
Car.
Let's see the
what
was that? Write out command.
Endpoint status.
Mhmm.
Dash dash right out table.
See, one of the good things about this
is obviously we have no idea what we're
doing with entity but I feel like I'm
learning how to work with entity. I
do feel as though I am I'm learning
a little bit. I mean, I have written
a bunch of code around Raft before and
found that very weird.
But a learning experience, but finding out how,
I guess this database sits on top of
Raft is is kinda interesting.
Yeah.
I'm gonna run that defrag and then this
is the leader. So I'm gonna do that
right out JSON again, get the revision ID
and
then we're gonna run compact
on 730154.
It did we get the defog already?
Did that revision ID change? No.
11301.
That worked on the other machine, didn't it?
It did. Yeah.
It's
it's Rawkode version. Oh, required revision has been
compacted.
So Oh, okay.
But it's still no space, still have the
same error. Yeah. The db size is now
only two meg.
Well,
we're saving disk space one way or another.
Alright. Let's see.
Wally just dropped us a hint. He's feeling
sorry for us now. Check the etcd manifest
in here. So I guess something different on
this note perhaps.
Yeah. I'll let you scroll through this.
Looks like my screen has an update with
this particular
one.
Over on the oh, I don't remember.
BJLW4Node.
Okay.
True LCD manifest in here. Okay.
Quote to back end bytes kind of stands
out to me there.
Oh, yeah. It has been changed here.
Before we actually change that, let's
oh.
The
dates on a few things are different here,
but definitely, that CD has been modified.
Yep.
I'm just gonna pop to the other node
and see how that one looks.
So I'm just in the other window at
the moment. I'm on M 5 r. Yeah.
I've got it. Okay.
I'll use less so people oh, I can't.
Cool. You want me to tape a tape?
Oh, you got it?
Okay. So that line isn't even oh, That's
the current back end bytes that you put
in, wasn't it? Yeah. I made up that
number.
Okay. We could probably just take that out
I suppose.
Or
maybe we should copy it from the other
node so they're the same consistently across all
the members of the cluster.
Let me check the control plane node and
just tell you if there's anything different.
So Kubernetes manifest has anything here been changed.
Right. No. That's actually No. This is this
is fresh.
Does it even have the thing in there?
It does not. So I think we just
remove the quarter back end base from all
of them and let it restart. So
I've removed it from the one control play
node that begins with b.
If you wanna just remove it from that
node that you're on there.
Oh, this is just a less, isn't it?
Oh, yep.
Let me try and then my way through
it. So
done.
Alrighty.
Did you you'd removed it from the one
I set. I have. I have. Yeah. Okay.
So
there is no maximum sizes on things now.
What was the endpoint
status?
Oh, status endpoint.
Yeah.
Right. Oh, it's such a terrible name for
that flag. It yeah.
I'm still getting the no alarm the no
space alarm.
I don't know if this will take some
time to
Yeah. If our SSD has even restarted yet,
guess.
13 20 5. Yeah. Potentially. Let's give it
a minute.
I mean we can see where the cube
CTL is actually giving us a working cluster
at this point.
Yeah. Why not? Every
time I click on that I really should
have used real service. Let's
go to this is five export. Okay. Get
notes.
Hey.
We're back in action.
Our pods
all running,
grab dash v.
HCD is coming up on one of them.
Mhmm.
System.
Just create pod.
Ah, okay. We've got one more thing to
fix it looks like.
What is that?
So which which node is this? I really
should have checked. So contain
white.
That was a stupid thing to grip on
wasn't it? No. Because it's not an inverse.
There we go. We wanna jump onto m
five r z g then.
Okay. Which we are.
Now what was that error again? Sorry. Wait
a minute.
Scatterbrained.
Yeah.
It can't open
host. Let's see hosts.
So is it maybe using host networking or
something?
It is, but it should. Right? Does that
city use host network? Yes. Yeah. Because it
binds to local host.
This looks like a file issue though.
I'm trying to access that Etsy hosts.
Let's get proper logs from it to either
it. Just
cattle.
Older and new. Older and new.
I'm still getting them. Yeah. It's still the
size thing.
What's the
time currently? So these are yeah. These are
from a minute ago. Yeah. Well, it says
it's just three more simple things. Yes. Thanks,
Ovid. Oh.
I I deeply regret upsetting you last week,
but I think I think you've definitely
taken your revenge here.
Alright. Let's
what's going on?
What have you done?
Blah blah blah. That looks fine.
That'd be it. Nothing.
Is there anything else in the config
in the in the flags that are being
passed?
So
advertising, fine. Data, blah blah blah.
All the peers are all there.
What are we missing here?
I mean, I I'm not actually seeing
this all looks fine to me.
It does.
Wonder if that log is just
well wrong.
Let's just check.
Editor opening of our lab kubelip
pods Etsy hosts.
I'm gonna just copy this file path actually.
Why would
think why would that fail?
Is this an old error? Are we are
we doing a really long loop back five
minute wait before restarting it or something?
Know, you're it's it's definitely possible of course.
Bar log containers
tail etcd.
No. It's still
it's still morning.
But I feel like we fixed this error.
The no space one.
Yes. No. Absolutely.
Let's run.
We have access to etcd.
We were running endpoint health.
Good. We run endpoint status.
We're still getting that alarm.
Yes.
There's leader, there's learner, blah blah blah. The
db size is
tiny compared to where it needs to be.
We actually fix all those manifests
quota.
Yes. There's none in the third one.
So that is
R8M5
and this is also R8.
It's going to be I'm sure I've got
multiple windows in each thing though but
What have you done now? There is no
quarters on any of this.
I think SCD is still restarting.
It is. You're right.
Why are you restarting?
So,
I mean, yeah, it restarted two
minutes ago.
Looks like I said he's popular. Jason also
tried to do some STD carnage on his
cluster, but then do some STD carnage. STD
on his
cluster, but then
break it in the way heats up.
Starting as a member. Yep.
Added as members as expected.
Started streaming with peers.
And then we got the same error.
No space.
Should we run a compaction on them all
again? Just
Founded valid file directory a b c. That's
one that you created, isn't it? So ignore
that. You just made sure that you could
actually write to the I did. Yeah.
Mhmm.
So we're still just getting effects of the
error that we're still getting is
no space.
Even though we removed the quota bytes, we've
restarted the etcd.
Alright. Well, it's we're approaching the end of
our time, so if you wanna throw us
a hint to get us past this, that
would be appreciated.
I joined out JSON and to see if
there's anything. I wanna see the revision ID,
I wanna know if it's changed. I wanna
kinda I feel like I should check it
across the nodes. Yeah. The revisions are same.
So '70 o one The version is same.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well, it has given us a command which
I will type in.
Endpoint
and paint. That's wishful thinking. Let's do this
right. At this point, definitely.
Egrep.
Wish
I could copy this.
Oh, nine star.
The original is the same one that we
used.
Yeah. Alright. I'm gonna should it be a
compaction we're running? I'll do a defrag and
a compact again, I guess.
730154.
There's a yeah, it's already been compacted.
Jason,
did we clear the alarms? They probably don't
clear themselves.
Clear
alarms.
No. Alarms clear.
Let's see what we've got.
Alarm less than disarm.
Alarm less. Alarm disarm.
Disarm.
It's gone. Alright.
Let's
do we need to do that in all
the nodes? I hope not. Let's go back
into
our container logs
and see if it stops restarting now.
Oh, hello. It's healthy.
I think it's healthy.
Clear alarms people,
apparently.
That's my tip of the day.
Get pods. Great. Are they all running?
There we go.
Almost.
So
I think we may have to clear the
alarm on the other two notes. It doesn't
look like that is automatic.
I know Jason does say that it's cluster
wide. Maybe I'm just being very impatient, but
we can check. We've got them all open.
Right? So
does I not download it on this machine?
I'm
sure I've got it somewhere on all machines.
I'm going to the wrong directory. That's why.
There we go. Okay. So
Are you in CD?
I know.
It's
time being particularly
wonderful today
and I won't have all those exports will
I?
Cheat sheet.
This is now my favorite is page in
the world.
What happened there? They're all running now. Oh,
are they? Just to make it. Yes.
Alright. This took some time.
Oh, my goodness.
That
was fun.
I well, your definition of fun is mine.
I mean,
databases.
Well, we need to check that the application's
working.
You mean the WordPress app?
Yes.
I actually don't think that ever broke.
I think it was quite happy just working
away in the background.
Maybe we never tested it.
Oh,
I mean
let's restart it.
There's his read me which said that they
were trying to do curls internally.
I wonder if he's broken internal DNS or
something.
Alright. Let's see if this pod restart gets
it online and running.
We can jump and say that we could
test quickly pod networking
quickly.
Can tell you what's missing here from doing
a quick get pods.
It's always DNS.
Call DNS isn't running.
Do a get pods minus capital a and
grep for DNS? Okay. So WordPress to put
forward work. It just couldn't yeah. Okay. So
there's no good service discovery.
Sorry. I'll use this. I shall shared.
So
namespace get
pods.
Windows. I need to contain myself next time.
Cooper. I can't even spell Cooper. We
have no cube
DNS.
Now how harsh has he been? Do we
have
They also the API server and things like
that are missing. Alright. Like there's there's
a bit of a problem there
Two unready pods.
Let's describe our deployment.
I don't see a scheduling adder, which is
what I was kind of expecting. Is it
We're probably
replica failure, replica create, minimum replicas
blah blah blah.
Why have we not got a scheduling error
here?
Mean, that's because all events are missing.
They would have been in the database.
Oh, we don't have an API server or
scheduler.
We don't we don't have a control plane.
Yes. I was wondering about that.
And I wonder if you've done something funny
with the manifest so that they're in a
namespace that doesn't exist.
Alright. I'll take a look
at cube API server. We've got a pod.
Namespace cube system.
Yeah. They're all that's all fine.
We have an API server. Maybe it's just
not come online yet. Should we just reboot
them?
I mean, taking a CD off is normally
quite catastrophic. This could just be a side
effect. Side effect.
Yeah. I'll just kill dash name.
I'm not gonna get my old complete. Copy
the ped.
Give it a second.
Alright. Okay. It's back.
Does that now show up?
No.
So our API server logs are what we
need. Right?
So why is
not
coming up?
Because there's no scheduler.
Let's cat
this.
Do you see an error?
I
am.
I know I'm scrolling fast.
Yeah. If you pop out here
look at the scheduler logs.
Scheduler.
I can't reach
API server.
So the scheduler can't reach the
what have you done now? Honestly, this is
this is a good one.
It's it's getting connection refused on port
on 14540.
Let's check the IP address.
14568143.
Alright. So has the port changed?
That looks alright to me.
Secure port 683.
I'm pretty sure we should remove that in
secure port. That's not even a thing anymore.
Right?
Has the style changed?
Yes.
Right. Yeah.
I don't think insecure that's not been a
thing for a while.
I'm just gonna look and see if I
see anything.
The line of this probe be going over
the IP or should it be used in
the pod IP?
Like 127001.
I mean, we haven't checked to see if
this is restarting or if it's
running but not working.
Time out some immediate seconds like okay. Yeah.
They don't worry me.
This is stressful.
Look. I can't see any gray hair underneath
this packet hat, so I'm good to go.
Alright. Let's
API server's not there anymore.
If you edited the file then it'll be
restarted.
Ah. Yeah. You're right.
Okay. So this is PED7417.
Is that gonna change?
Mean, I can
kill local host 6443
is fine so I can loop back to
the API server.
And secure. Yeah.
That's good.
This So there's nothing This must be networking.
But what they what they
So how did API servers elect the leader?
Because
To do it through the to do it
through the.
Sailorium's okay.
Are you okay for time? Because I know
we've went a bit over.
Yeah. I'm okay. Okay.
Jason is telling us to use the Hubble
UI.
We do have it available.
I guess it wouldn't hurt to take a
look with it.
Okay.
It's a good idea. Hubble is a really
cool product as part of the sub m
c n a.
That will show us if there's any
network
policies or traffic being blocked, etcetera.
I don't know what port it runs on.
And now I feel like I'm
I need to change my command from here.
Not configured.
Getting myself in a pickle.
Describe
pod
UI.
Give me a port
80. I really should have just took a
shot on that.
Alright.
So if we browse to this IP address
of 80 80.
Nothing's gonna happen.
Alright.
Can't be bothered fighting with that. Okay.
Well, it says think
simple Kubernetes resources.
Let's just stick to what we know.
Are there any network policies?
Yes.
Scrape NetPol
MVP one.
That just seems to be in the live
everything, doesn't it? Yeah.
Hello, created yesterday at 6PM. So I'm gonna
delete it.
I'm gonna suppose to allow any egress traffic
not with that block any
external.
Actually, this was a block all.
Yep.
Well, you've just given a sense. It's still
feeling pretty. What hates pods? Right? Why would
something not show up on get pods?
Let's take a look at the
Yeah.
I'm starting to draw a blank here.
Right. I only have a few minutes and
then I I really need to leave.
So we'll we'll go for three more minutes.
If we don't get it, we don't get
it. That's fine. We will get the post
mortem into the read me while these will
add all of his notes to tell us
what he did. We can all learn from
that. I can imagine his notes are gonna
be a book at this. I
must have spent a week doing this.
Better run a git all, see if I
can see anything.
I don't wanna give up.
Alright. He said check pod security policies.
So
the speaker will be met They'll be the
Rooker's Rook. That no privilege.
I'm gonna describe
What's this thing?
Allow privilege escalation true. Run is only run
is only running.
I don't think that's
am I misreading that?
It's called null privilege but it doesn't appear
to be blocking anything.
Let's just delete it.
Well, it's there you go. He's dropping some
knowledge on us now. No privilege hates static
pods.
I had no
idea.
I mean, I've hidden static pods by putting
if you put a different namespace that doesn't
exist in the static pod,
cubes kubelet will start it, but the API
server doesn't know what to do it do
with it.
Okay. So with that gone, we should see
things like the API server.
Yeah. I'm wondering if it's only the wee
cheeky push, though.
I shouldn't think so.
I've given up just assuming I know anything
anymore so.
Alright. What machine are we on? That is
m five r eight
and
I'll give this last one a push because
we're wrapping up.
See if we even have a working API
server yet. It's so weird I'm creating the
API server and I can't see it on
a pod list.
It is quite confusing, isn't it? Yep. Still
cast there.
He says this one last issue something to
do with the kernel sentence for forward and
I mean, I definitely have my depth there.
So that's ETC
CTL. Alright.
What have we got?
What's the date on these?
There's some Selium configurations here.
So he's disabled something,
I guess, in /etcsysCTL.com.
Always done it manually, I guess.
Yeah. I think it's been done manually. Those
fails look fine to me.
I'm gonna need to lie down after this.
Man alive. I've never been so stressed in
my life. This is insane.
I'm gonna concede. I'm sorry. I don't think
we're gonna get it, Ari.
We're It doesn't it certainly doesn't look like
it.
The the API server is still hidden
inside the API which is kind of amusing.
Alright.
So let's let's let's call it. Like, we
we could fix valid cluster.
I'm looking forward to reading what you actually
done and learning. I love that trick with
the no privilege. I mean even looking at
that podcast security policy, I was like it's
not doing anything.
Definitely need to research that more and understand
why
that hates a static pod benefit, have static
pods like I just
right now I don't understand that at all.
Alright,
thank you Jason, thank you for lead, those
were both extremely tough. Thank you. That
was
was brutal. I I will take at least
we got one cluster up and we got
kind of partially towards
this one. Yeah. But that was that was
that was pretty brutal.
Thank you. Yeah.
Alright. Dan,
thank you for working through that with me.
It is stressful. It is fun.
I'm learning stuff. I hope others are learning
stuff too. Thank you for everyone that joined
us for that massive two hour session.
Alright. I'm gonna get for a long time.
Yeah. Let's take a nice break, well deserved.
Alright. I'll speak to you soon. Everyone else,
thanks a lot. I'll see you soon. Bye,
everyone.